pour moi même c'est à dire qu'on peut
manipuler l'information c'est pas pour
ça que les gens vont la gober forcément
ouais je crois que les gens qui viennent
de voir ces sujets crois que mme un
service football là il ya un moment
quand même où l'info tu as vraiment
foutu les boules
c'était pendant la guerre du golfe là tu
t'es tu t'es vraiment énervé tu va
appeler ça une boucherie mais us
hvr yeux et ça tu as vraiment énervé ça
un peu oui pourquoi
et pour plein de raisons déjà voir les
médias donc tu es fais partie je vois
des mecs des journalistes français
habillés en treillis camouflage kaki
dans le désert en train de
habillés en militaires enfin nous donner
comme information ce qu'ils recevaient
de l'état major américain
cette pitoyable quoi réaliser que toute
démocratie qu'on soit quand le pouvoir
veut museler la presse et les
journalistes
ils sont en garde à vous donc ça ça m'a
fait gerber depuis c'était une guerre
pour ce que j'ai pas aimé c'est
l'hypocrisie du discours quoi la guerre
du droit pour rétablir la démocratie
elle a rétabli quoi les émirs
c'est jaber au koweit cela dit un truc
bien sûr les coverity au passage qui est
assez drôle tu dis avant que va être le
cobaye qui était sur son bourricot il a
failli marcher derrière maintenant elle
marche devant à cause des mines fut bref
on m'a demandé ça mais c'est sûrement
vrai en plus ce bon pour virer saddam
hussein ils n'ont pas à dire elle est
toujours là il est plus puissant que
jamais maintenant c'est un héros aux
yeux du monde arabe le problème
palestinien on devait entrer dans cette
guerre pour être à la table des
négociations n'a même pas un strapontin
tu as marqué sur la sur la pochette de
son disque enregistré pendant leur sale
guerre c'est vraiment quelque chose de
laid courage 1
c'est courageux oui parce que tu t'es
fait quand même traité de sade amis de
vichyssois de collabos collabos
d'antisémite
ouais on a dit qu'il voulait rayer
israël de la carte c'est pas on analyse
guy bedos qui allait s'imposer quand je
disais libérer la palestine j'entendais
par palestine autre chose que les
territoires occupés que donc il a écrit
dans un journal en pleine guerre du
golfe que je voulais gomme et israël
je me voyais déjà avec une bombe apporte
mon disque aurait pu être concevable en
plus de la peur des juifs mais qui
veulent rallier israël de la carte
je lui ai répondu que c'était une tête
de con et que ses propos étaient quand
même dans ce monde nul mais dangereux
comme une honte pour moi pour les miens
et où vous êtes bien gueuler rythme et
un an après tu persistes et u6 sur la
condamnation de la guerre du hub à
huawei encore plus encore plus
bah oui ça engendrait un génocide enfin
massacre de kurdes de plus saddam a
liquidé son opposition secure détour
tranquille
marc hecker temps est revenu aussi parce
que tu t'es aperçus qu'ils avaient
massacré les arméniens c'est compliqué
et plus fin il avait collaboré avec tes
participer quelques-uns d'entre eux ont
dû bien ils sont pas tout blanc blanc
blanc personne n'est blanc ballon il ya
plein de gens comme ça qui t'avait qui
l'avaient soutenu et puis qui finalement
sont un peu détaché de toi je vais
donner des noms comme ça au hasard
anne sinclair par exemple m'a soutenu
elle fait alors qu'elle les élections l
époque où tu faisais les beaux jours du
magazine globe et tous anne sinclair
était quand même faisait partie des gens
qui tu es mais bientôt c'est un peu la
bonne conscience de la gauche et même
plus maintenant je crois que tous ces
gens là fait beaucoup moins qu'avant mon
fabuleux autant douter non bernard henri
lévy par exemple
je passe te pousse aussi des gens de
cette école de tir au pigeon d'argile de
son nom mais c'est des gens se séparent
à ces gens que j'aime pas causé des îles
mal et du pouvoir et lèche-bottes des
socialo les gens qui jugent qu'ils
condamnent qui des donneurs de leçons et
où vous le voyez un type qui était un
peu remplacé comme pub qu'on sort de la
gauche c'est bruel bon tagaeri et qu'il
y aller un peu au chagrin et à ma place
alors qu'un succès m'agace mais lui
lagarde charland que concurrent quoi
ouais t'es jaloux lui pas jaloux mais
c'est toujours énervant je l ai un mec
qui pulvérise des scores à ce niveau là
quoi je veux dire c est quand même une
compétition ce métier on a toujours
envie d'être le premier meilleur ou dans
le groupe de tête et a dit qu'il avait
rien à dire je dis ça à moi oui on a
l'eau tgb toussaint dans politis seul et
qu'il avait rien à dire et il était
large et lyon et il fallait les arrêter
laurent marti un jour on a parlé de
laurent fabius et tu as dit je peux
faire che guevara c'est toujours vrai
nom mais j'avais lu un article d'une
gamine de 20 ans personnage que vous
préférez c'est tellement fabuleux idéal
de société ce que tend vers che guevara
non mais je pense plus qu'à 20 ans je
préfère être gélébart hab et encore
aujourd'hui bien fait petit en pense
quoi
c'est un non c'est même pas un bon
gestionnaire d'une équipe de jeunes de
bonne équipe de football là je veux dire
apparemment les résultats de son nom ça
mais que j'aime pas trop quoi que c'est
un fonceur sa maman cgc diffamatoires ça
non je veux dire on parle de jouer le
jeu sur soi si ces entreprises qui
rachète et tout qui fait soi disant
fleurir en fait il y fait en fleurir en
licenciant 90% les ouvriers qui se
retrouvent à la rue ou restaurants du
coeur
serge july tu dis maintenant il défend
la social-démocratie l'élu s'en émeut le
dernière le premier arabe
alors c'est marrant parce que le seul
qui trouve grâce à ses yeux c'est jean
edern hallier
ouais tu as dit j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour rejoindre amélie alors
ils sont même bien j'en ai des regrets
de l'avoir beaucoup d'admiration pour
lui à 6 et 1 2 6 6 d'abord parce que
c'est le plus grand écrivain un des plus
grands écrivains français vivant c'est
ce que mitterrand lui a dit d'ailleurs
lui un jour et
et puis c'est un fou quoi il a peur de
rien c'est un homme divorcé un sauvage
années sert à ça c'est un
et puis c'est un diamant et il est
génial
et puis ils essaient de le faire taire
j'aimerais les mecs qu'on essaie de
faire taire il y avait un temps en
interdisaient charlie hebdo pour le bal
tragique à colombey
aujourd'hui ont foulé procès en
diffamation et c'est peut-être parce que
c'est les grosses amendes varient d g en
un problème dont on n'a jamais vu ça
dans l'histoire de la presse 1 million
800 mille nouveaux 185 d'amendé pour
diffamation envers eric ouvre ses biens
qui est ramollie patronale de la piste
ou cinq fois c'est bien tu te ramolli
pas trop le pen tu as dit aujourd'hui si
on veut être un fin cathodique
il faut balancer sur le pen je suis un
petit peu énervé qu'on a parlé ces
espèces de tous les artistes ou les
intellectuels tous les journalistes tous
aimé qu'ils arrivent à la télé qui font
leur petit couplet anti l'open quoi
ras le bol et ps2 c'est comment dire
c'est une espèce de créneaux quoi toi de
positionnement marketing sévère
positionnement marketing humaniste aux
droits de l'homme à elle ça tu aimes pas
alors dis-moi coluche bien ce bourg
montans a touché disparition de l'enfant
ouais tu es bien j'aimais bien l'artiste
l'homme l'homme de position pas trop aux
prêts quand il fait ses émissions de
télé vive la crise
vive la guerre qui nous expliquaient les
yeux dans les yeux pourquoi elle va
l'aider à 16 ans avait pas d pershing
pourquoi il y aurait la guerre si on
faisait pas comme ci ou comme ça
pourquoi la crise est-elle inévitable
qu'il fallait serrer la ceinture et tout
élément 80 au passage tout ça c'est un
peu gonflé mais l'artiste le comédien
une chanteur c'était un grand bonhomme